what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
man it's been a little while since we've
done the character explanation like nine
months it's been almost a year since
we've done the character explanation the
issue with these is that they take a
long time to put together quite some
time and honestly it's actually been so
long I've almost forgotten how to make
them it's pitiful that's terrible isn't
it anyway in this video we're going to
be covering the vulture Adrian Toomes
now something to keep in mind there have
been different iterations of the vulture
over the course of Marvel's publication
history and so because the vulture
Adrian Toomes was going to be the main
villain in spider-man homecoming we're
really just going to kind of stick with
him we're not going to worry about the
other versions of the vulture but Adrian
Toomes first appeared in Marvel Comics
with the amazing spider-man issue number
two in May of 1963 and he was actually
created by Stan Lee and Steve Ditko now
something that I want to point out here
to kind of sidetrack for a second most
people when they look at the early
creations of Marvel back in the 1960s
really with this second age of
superheroes so to speak a lot of people
look at Stan Lee and Jack Kirby as the
one-two punch in a lot of ways they were
the Fantastic Four the x-men Thor Iron
Man these were all basically creations
at the hands of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
Steve Ditko was the helping hand or
really was the major source of
inspiration when it came to the idea of
spider-man and the reason why I say that
is because of the fact that Jack Kearney
had an art style that limited itself
towards the idea of heroic looking
figures a very much followed the idea of
traditional hero so that really goes
back to the idea that Jack Kirby had a
hand in the early days of DC Comics but
the idea here was that with spider-man
Stan Lee was looking for an artistic
rendering of the character that didn't
lend itself towards an established hero
instead Peter Parker was supposed to be
the kid that basically had no idea what
he was doing but the goal was that as
the spider-man stories continued on the
fans would basically grow with Peter
Parker as Peter Parker began to
understand what it meant to be a hero
and began to grasp what it was that he
was doing and so the result was that
with Steve Ditko having this art style
that very much lint itself to the
free-flowing nature of what the
spider-man stories had to be ultimately
we ended up having a Stan Lee work
alongside Steve Ditko to basically flesh
out the spider-man landscape and so what
we got with the idea of Adrian Toomes
was that an issue number two we did not
get a full-fledged backstory instead he
was just there he was just a villain who
already had his vulture suit and he was
an enemy of spider-man and
the origin of Adrian Toomes as we know
him didn't actually come until untold
tales of spider-man issue number 20 in
1997 written by Kurt Busiek
and the untold tales of spider-man were
basically designed to go back and either
deal with existing characters or flesh
out the backstory of established
characters in lays that simply simply
hadn't been done before for example
there's one issue having edition of a 21
that deals with the idea of the first
time that Spiderman met the x-men but
with Adrian Toomes what we end up
finding out here is that he was
initially a business partner of a man
named Gregory vestment Gregory bessman
had actually been embezzling money out
of the company that himself and Adrian
Toomes were working with the problem
with this was that it was done using a
legal loophole and so what that meant
was that Adrian Toomes
had no recourse for the actions that
have been taken by Gregory vestment and
so ultimately Adrian Toomes effectively
lost his job and so what this meant was
that going into a life of crime Adrian
Toomes sought to get his own revenge
against spider-man now the funny thing
about this is that this origin story
almost deals only with really the events
that took place before his first
encounter with spider-man within the
first page or so it's really not that
lengthy on the other hand his initial
appearance in amazing spider-man number
two offers a little more meat and
potatoes and the reason why is because
this actually coincides with the idea a
Peter Parker getting a job selling
photos to the Daily Bugle and Jay jonah
Jameson and the reason for this is
because of the fact that once Adrian
Toomes
basically takes to a life of crime what
it begins doing is just stealing
precious jewels and diamonds from
different people which means that by the
time individuals arrive on the scene or
the police show up nobody really can
snap a picture of them instead all they
do is they just have some kind of you
know artistic rendering by the person
who claims to have seen him in the first
place software's keep in mind at this
time when the story was written this was
just designed to kind of introduce these
villains that weren't necessarily
extremely dark or extremely dangerous I
mean you would never see like a William
Stryker
for example within the confines of the
story the early Spider Man stories were
designed to focus on a light-hearted
nature of Stanley's traditional story
tone Stanley has routinely stated on
record that is gold when he was writing
these early comics was to have this sort
of thrill of the danger that's thrill of
the hunt but to never really have
superheroes or even super villains lives
in mortal jeopardy and so with Peter
Parker coming to the realization that if
nobody is able to snap pictures of the
vulture that he can engage
conflict and snapped pictures while it
happens but he basically begins the
process of setting things up now
somebody keep in mind is that when it
comes to Peter Parker's spider-sense in
these early comics it was still being
fleshed out and so the idea was that
while Peter was getting used to it he
could still be overcome to a degree now
of course with Peter Parker rising in
prominence as spider-man the spider
students began to play more and more of
a role in his line of stories to the
point that was virtually unavoidable to
make it intriguing and make it something
that would have him avoid any number of
conceivable dangerous threats but
essentially being taken by surprise by
Adrian Toomes being whisked away into a
water tower and effectively left there
spider-man's basically able to make his
escape and then sell his pictures to Jay
jonah jameson beginning the relationship
between the two of them but it also
allows for Adrian Toomes to go forward
with his plan and his plan is to
actually throw a rock with a letter into
the Daily Bugle telling them that he's
going to steal the Diamonds that are
supposed to be shipped in and so again
this brings spider-man into the equation
in trying to find a way to stop the
vulture and also leads to the vulture
successfully stealing the diamonds by
actually coming out from the gutters and
that's one of the interesting things
about Stan Leeds early writing is
because when it came to these different
kinds of villains it was the creative
nature of them for the character of
Adrian Toomes if he's called the vulture
and he flies around committing crimes
then what better way to trick people
into believing that he's going to do
something then by coming from a place
they don't expect and so again it's a
pretty cool concept but of course
spider-man is ultimately able to catch
up to him he apprehends the vulture the
vultures arrested and of course that
leads into the first time the two of
them basically become mortal enemies now
where the vulture was really charted up
is like the second major villain a
really the second villain with
spider-man ever faced where the
chameleon having come in first for the
most part the both who remain largely
absent from the spider-man line of
stories for about the next two years he
did appear but it was by no means in the
same capacity that he had appear the
first time now the reason for this was
because of the fact with spider-man
growing in popularity at a rapid pace in
the early days of marble the goal of
Stan Lee and Steve Ditko was to
basically begin going through and
creating a rogues gallery as to what we
ended up seeing between the introduction
of vulture going into his return was
that in May of 1963 July of 1963
September of 1963 November of 1963 and
January of 1964 we started seeing
characters like Tigre dr. octopus
Sandman lizard
and living brain as well as electro and
a handful of others and so what this
meant was that by the time the amazing
spider-man annual number one came out in
1964 and the vulture finally found his
return Marvel was going in the direction
of beefing up its rogues gallery and
then bringing them together in the form
of the sinister six
now the sinister six was really this
sort of coming together of different
villains for the main spider-man
character and the return of Adrian
Toomes was really involved only in so
far but he was one of the many villains
that was brought together to defeat
spider-man but the overarching goal of
Doctor Octopus was to put spider-man
through this sort of gauntlet that would
see him facing off against each
individual member of his robes gallery
of course and this particular sinister
stakes are in the very first iteration
they came in the form of Doc Ock himself
electro Kraven the hunter Mysterio
Sandman and of course vulture and with
the entire event centering around the
idea that Doctor Octopus had kidnapped
Peter Parker's first love interest in
the form of Betty Brant as well as on
May it created this idea of Peter
fighting each member of the sinister six
and a place that was the most conducive
to their abilities for example keep
ended up fighting electro and a major
power plant but the idea was that with
the vulture he would basically fight him
in the air now again because of the fact
that this was designed to give new
readers a virtual tour of the different
villain Peter Parker of course was able
to defeat vulture and ultimately it led
to him gaining the location of Doctor
Octopus and inevitably freeing Aunt May
and Betty Brant but with issue number 38
1966 seeing the departure of Steve Ditko
as Potter and artist and John Romita
taking over his place the spider-man
stories began to take a more serious
tone to a degree to keep in mind that in
the 1960s going into the 1970s comic
books were still pretty light-hearted
especially in Marvel so long as Stanley
was the one who was writing them but the
idea was that with John Romita senior
taking over the goal was to begin the
process of moving us by demand stories
in a more serious tone when you combine
this with the idea that between 1964 and
1966 we sort of seen the introduction of
villains like Scorpion the Green Goblin
and kingpin what this meant was that for
about three years the vulture was
virtually non-existent in the Amazing
Spiderman line of stories but in 1967
Stanley and John Romita senior sought to
reintroduce the vulture with a more
updated theme by having Adrian Toomes
replaced by a man named Bernero Drago
now the idea here was to basically
introduce a guy who would effectively
tricked Adrian Toomes into
revealing the location of a second
vulture suit the issue with this was
that the response was either mixed or
nobody really seemed to care and so
going into 1968 the vulture appeared as
Adrian Toomes a couple more times and
then vanished for almost ten years now
by 1977 the spider-man line of stories
had experienced a paradigm shift for
several reasons the first was a cause of
the fact that was spider-man continuing
to increase in popularity Marvel
answered by expanding the spider-man
line of stories which meant there we
ended up getting increases to the
existing spider-man line that came in
the form of Marvel team-up spider-man
team-up giant-sized spider-man which is
a six issued limited series Peter Parker
the spectacular spider-man the web of
Spiderman that came in 1985 these were
all a line of publications that all
basically included spider-man himself
and there were much much more there was
spider-man unlimited and so on and so
forth a lot of these came after 1977 but
the other half of this was the writing
of Gerry Conway with several writers
having taken over the spider-man
landscape following the departure of
Stan Lee Gerry Conway was one of the
most important because of the fact that
he had basically written a story called
the night Gwen Stacy died and the night
of gwen stacy raya dying was one of the
most important stories in the history of
comics because of the fact that it
introduced the idea that a superhero
could fail and with superheroes failing
and their loved interests effectively
dying what this did was set the stage
for the removal of superheroes from the
realm of being in science fiction and
fantasy and creates stories that could
be more intertwined more tangible and
more realistic now the spider-man line
of stories had already you know always
done this but the idea was that with the
vulture they could bring him back and
make him more than just a character who
is this guy who was just going to rob
jewel spider-man would catch him and
throw him in jail and so in March of
1977 with writer Archie Goodwin having
launched spectacular spider-man the
vulture returned with issue number four
now this return in and of itself was not
by any means extremely important instead
what came were ancillary stories
afterwards was a darker and grittier
version of Adrian Toomes
in Peter Parker's spectacular spider-man
volume 1 issue number 44 written by Marv
Wolfman the vulture had arranged for the
murder of an existing mob boss in order
to be able to take over his empire and
arrange for the defeat of spider-man in
the amazing spider-man number 240 in
1983 written by Howard Stern the vulture
tracked down his old business partner
Gregory investment an attempt to take
him out and in 1992 with spectacular
spider-man issue
number 186 written by J M DeMatteis this
was achieved when the vulture killed it
in 1990 with amazing spider-man issue
number 336 written by david michelinie
the actions of the vulture in kidnapping
Aunt May led to the intervention of her
boyfriend at the time Nathan lubinski
which results in him suffering a heart
attack after realizing the vulture had
taken him into the air and as a
follow-up to his murder of Gregory
investment in spectacular spider-man
issue number 186 and spectacular
spider-man issues 187 and 188 the
vulture ended up learning that he had
cancer and Aunt May wish that he would
die these stories and stories like it
were attempts by Marvel to basically
bolster the vulture and make him a more
notable villain make him somebody that
could basically stand out but on the
whole most people who looked at his
character saw him as a holdover from the
early Stanley days of stories this was
compounded by the fact that in a lot of
ways the vulture was not nearly as
notable or as capable as the Green
Goblin when Osborn as the kingpin who
really found his claim to fame as a
notable villain of daredevil under Frank
Miller as well as a handful of other
characters who have been reworked or
reimagine over the years and so going
from the mid-1990s into the 2000s in the
2010 s where efforts were made by
writers like Robert roadied with
identity disc or Fred van linty or Dan
Slott during his run on spider-man big
time growing up into the modern day in
the face of villains like carnage and
venom the revamped kingpin as well as
Doctor Octopus at superior spider-man
ultimately weaves up finding the vulture
just kind of fell into the backdrop he
was just a character who was reminiscent
of an Asian comics that doesn't really
apply anymore he was one of spider-man's
most most notable in early villains but
in the face of newer villains who were a
lot more gruesome who were dangerous
those who had an immunity to
spider-man's spider-sense ultimately
vulture was just a guy with wings who
flew around and robbed stuff or at least
that's how a lot of fans seem to view
him now one of the biggest questions
that I've had when it came to spider-man
homecoming is why the vulture of all the
villains they could choose you know
venom or carnage or Doctor Octopus or
just the combination of the sinister six
why the vulture and there was an
interview that was done on Collider
where one of the producers Erik Harrell
had talked about the idea of the vulture
and one of the things that he said was
that with spider-man because of the fact
that he's basically ground level which
is to say he's a superhero that you do
see in cosmic events but on the whole
his stories usually have him
with things on the street-level it made
sense to grab a street-level character a
street-level villain and because of the
fact that Adrian Toomes is very much
rooted in the idea that he's a guy who
was this more or less cheated out of his
own company by his former business
partner it made sense to adapt that into
the form of perhaps him losing his job
at the hands of Tony Stark or Stark
Industries putting him out of business
whatever the case may be but making him
more of a grounded in a tangible
character as opposed to some cosmic
event and that makes sense in a lot of
ways because in the current state of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the phase one
films dealt with for the most part
tangible villains if the character was
rooted in earth-based events you had the
Red Skull who was basically or at least
was depicted to be the head of Hydra but
was still basically a human with
increased abilities on par with Captain
America Steve Rogers was a regular guy
until he was injected with the Super
Soldier Serum the same thing goes on
with agents of shield the only
characters that you see that are beyond
normal human beings are usually like
Thor who comes from Asgard a whole
different dimension and then you have
the Incredible Hulk who's a guy that
takes on an incredibly strong form so
it's still pretty grounded in terms of
the nature of spider-man and what he's
about and the vultures seem to highlight
the very essence of what spider-man is
or at least that's the explanation that
was given most likely in the argument
that I would make is that with Sony
effectively being the ones that are
backing the movie at the end of the day
because of the fact that Sony wanted to
use vulture in spider-man 4 it seems
like they're more or less just kind of
requiring that he be used in spider-man
homecoming we also know that Sony has
their own intention with what they're
going to do with venom
we know that Sony is kicking around the
idea of the sinister six we also know
that Sony apparently had a script where
Aunt May was going to be a secret agent
so we know that Sony is dealing with
these ideas of beefing up their own
characters beefing up their own rosters
as they own them as far as the right
scale in film form and so it makes sense
that Marvel would basically use the
character of vulture because it seems to
be the most tangible out of all the
different villains that they could use
now in terms of the different powers and
what he's capable of the vulture is
pretty straightforward he's by no means
one of the most powerful villains of
Marvel has not by any standard of
measurement without his wingsuit the
vulture is just a regular guy but there
have been exceptions to the rule and
different writers have actually depicted
this different ways in terms of its
harness the vultures harness basically
uses the electromagnetic spectrum and
anti graviton the electromagnetic aspect
allows him to basically maneuver the
suit without any real effort whatsoever
and allowing him
for almost perfect flight meaning he can
fly just like a bird can but with
regards to the antigravity on this
serves the purpose of negating the
effects of gravity on him and so we can
basically turn the suit into a glider of
sorts and then using its wings actually
steer himself in almost any direction
and fly for virtually an unlimited
amount of time now in terms of the
effects of the seat itself different
riders had to figure this different ways
there's been some writers who have said
that once he takes the suit off that you
still able to flow you still able to
basically fly due to some unexplained
phenomena most likely is the fact that
the harness has some kind of effect on
his you know cellular biology which
actually gives him the ability to float
or could just simply be the effects of
you know the antigravity are particles
in the sense that with anti-gravity
particles engaged once you take the suit
off they still affect him which means
that for a time gravity doesn't have an
effect on him so long as he tries to
lunge himself into the air or something
along those lines but again different
riders had taken different liberties
with this there have been some writers
who have said that so long as he simply
just acts like a normal human being just
sort of walks along or he tries to glide
without exerting himself too much that
ultimately it'll last you know a day or
two there are other riders who say
regardless of how he exerts himself
it'll only last a couple hours there's
no absolute rule when it comes to this
it's just whenever anybody any writer is
writing at any particular point in time
but in addition to the ability of flight
the harness also grants him
super-strength now it's not
super-strength it makes it unlimited
instead it's about the peak of human
potential as it was whatever in human
being could basically lift if they were
able to reach their full maximum so in
truth I would go as far as to say the
vulture is probably on par with Captain
America in terms of its physical
strength but again only so long as he's
wearing the harness and once the effects
have not worn off once the harness has
been taken off but with that being said
guys oh man yeah it's been a little
while since we did a character
explanation god I am rusty at this man
like I got to go back to the drawing
board on these things because it is man
it's tough like the hardest part of
doing character explanations I would say
would be taking that information and
trying to consolidate it in a way that
makes sense because my information on
the vulture is kind of fuzzy and there
may have been a few facts here in there
that I kind of you know kind of screwed
up I mean I tried to go through with all
the information that I have to saw they
did make sure that it's right but I
think we did a pretty good job with a
character who is
really obscure and who in a lot of ways
hasn't really done much to further the
spider-man mythos but with that being
said if you guys are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys should the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]